agnès b bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en ce grand jour
vous ouvrez donc votre première boutique
à votre première boutique mais votre
première boutique à versailles pourquoi
versailles
parce que j'y suis né parce que j'aime
cette ville parce que juge le château
m'a toujours inspiré genou est amené
beaucoup j'étais au buzzer de versailles
c'est les beaux arts de versailles
j'étais je dessinais beaucoup pendant
qu'elle allait à l'école jusqu'à mes 17
ans donc très bien et pourquoi avoir
attendu alors tout ce temps il ya eu
colabella pendant très longtemps qui
était fermée qui rit le bo xi a je me
suis dit pour eux je me mettrais pas là
en fait c'est comme ça que ces signes du
pays keating du pays mais j'ai bien cru
j'aime bien ce quartier oui c'est qu'on
lui tend à réduire et c'en est une c'est
un jeu au pied droit
voilà voilà alors je suis resté dans les
tons un peu du quartier le gris clair
les jours pas les voilà on est resté
dans des couleurs comme ça et j'ai bien
d'accord alors avant tout je voudrais
vous féliciter parce qu'il y est une
grande journée
vous avez été décoré de la légion
d'honneur à françois hollande va dire
que j'ai été fait commandeur de la
légion d'honneur commandeur michael
travail
oui j'ai alors qu'est ce que ça fait mal
et à vrai dire c'était la septième fois
que j'étais des corps et âme à facettes
et mitterrand en 81
d'accord j'ai commis par huawei qui
m'avait donné leur mérite décerné lors
du mérite
puis après j'ai eu la médaille des arts
et lettres d un peu habitué du sérail
alors oui c'est en grade et avec la
légion d'honneur il ya ces commandes
sommes maintenant presque envie table
soit dit que mon prof de maths ne
reviendrait pas mais pas trop et huit
mois cette boutique à l'ock qui est donc
enfin installé à versailles comment va
être comment dire animer ce lieu vous
prévoyez par les vêtements vous imaginer
d'autres choses à entendre la musique de
temps en temps des accrochages de
peintures d'artistes de la galerie du
jour de notre galerie peut-être viendra
ici qui viendrait où elle même qui fera
des choses sûrement d'accord assez rétif
quelquefois de la veille d'un musicien
d'accord là c'est mon ami danton qui
s'appelle danton cesson noya budget
c'est vrai qu'il est l'actrice colo qui
viennent jouer ce soir ouais à
versailles oui voilà
liette que votre journal pointe d'ironie
va distribuer oui bien sur le web en
ironie le journal de tara le bateau
justement quand on active et les voyages
oui le pointe d'ironie c'est un jour
najjar est ce que c'est qu'un point
d'ironie c'est un point d'ironie chez
trouvé ça dans le grand larousse du
xxème siècle au mot ironie ouais et bien
figurez vous qu'il ya un point d'ironie
comme le point d'exclamation que pour le
connais interrogations pour les jeunes
ne connaissaient et comme notre journal
qui est gratuit qui est diffusée est
diffusée dans beaucoup de pays
différents
on a choisi le point d'ironie on n'avait
pas déposé le nom puisque c'était dans
la période c'était à personne l'accord
comme ça on est un journal c'est quoi le
but de ce journal s'est donné huit pages
à un artiste il a tout toutes les pages
ya que lui d'abord il fait ce qu'il veut
il fait ce qu'il veut on en est au
numéro 59 je crois en verve apparaîtront
artiste on en fait 5 6 par an d'accord
et on les distribuer gratuitement dans
les boutiques dans des cinémas dans des
centres d'art dans une page blanche à un
artiste du wat cher à cent mille
exemplaires exemplaires avec mon ami
hans ulrich obrist peu des gens dans
l'art connaissent très bien c'est un
grand commissaire d'exposition et
christian boltanski qui est un des plus
grands artistes français contemporain
tous les trois on a eu l'idée d'une
dispersion dollar donc je vais lancer
via noir madrid au maximum de personnes
will ouvrir au maximum de personnes les
générations voilà que ça touche des gens
que ça leur voilà qui se posent des
questions qui est artiste faire
connaître des artistes de cette manière
d'accord alors que sa lutte
maintenant il est écrit comme ça en tout
si oui c'est l'artiste qui est vraiment
mis en avant et on n'a jamais fait de
publicité non mais c'est pas votre truc
là vie non mon agenda
donc pour revenir à taraz we dare à ce
bateau est l' or il est alors ta race et
le tard à celle de vingt ans ça fait 12
ans qu'on a acheté ce bateau qui avait
été dessinée par jean louis etienne qui
avait appartenu à sir peter blake s'est
effectué à bord et ça vous allez choisir
où elles par des pirates près du
venezuela et sa femme un peu nous a
choisis comme le pensant qu'on allait
faire quelque chose de bien avec ce
bateau et je pense qu'elle est contente
on la voit régulièrement et l'arrière on
enlève beaucoup et je crois qu'elle est
contente de ce qu'on fait à bord
alors justement vers un exploit y arrête
on est en a fait on a été au pôle nord
une dérive arctique on a été au pôle sud
on a fait le tour du monde et à chaque
fois on prélève de l'eau oui les océans
par exemple ça c'est tara océans ça
c'était un autre projet qu'on avait
c'était un projet d'il ya trois ans tara
océans donc les océans du monde voir
l'impact du réchauffement climatique
c'est une sorte de thermomètre la de
l'internet de la pollution c'est votre
grand chose
1 un microscope que nous a offert la
région bretagne le drian d'affaires un
microscope nous a permis de découvrir
des choses incroyables c'était sacré
attribution à taraz puisque son port
d'attaché lorient nous on adore la
bretagne n'est pas breton nous on aime
la bretagne comme je suis très contente
que ce soit lorient son port d'attaché
d'ailleurs quand il parle quand ils
arrivent les lorientais sont là les
bateaux accompagnant des magnifiques oui
elle va d'ailleurs bientôt au départ oui
j'ai vu par pour faire pour travailler
sur les coraux les coraux dans le
pacifique donc il va aller à miami là il
ya un grand truc à miami
et après il va prendre le canal de
panama et traverser lisse et à lui donc
dans le bus pendant deux ans et demi sur
la ville ont un long voyage très bien
donc vous êtes monté à m'engager
c'est ma contribution à l'écologie de
son tir tard l'un personnellement c'est
pas la maison anne sbc mois fait vous
arriver et maintenant tu as on vient de
faire de fond de baie de faire une
formation par un contraste ce qui permet
à des gens peut-être de nous aider de
contribuer belle alors changeons de même
oui vous êtes une femme engagée donc
dans l'écologie et hadji mais aussi dans
l'humanitaire déjà au temps de l'abbé
pierre vous étiez présente l abbé pierre
j'avais choisi de le rencontrer
m'avaient dit qu'ils voulaient vous
rencontrer jeudi l'abbé pierre
c'est le journal elle je croise aviez
droit à 3 me eric aubin cela j'avais
choisi l'abbé pierre et c'était une
rencontre formidable
est ce que moi je me souvenais quand
j'étais petit il y avait eu c'était en
56 l'hiver les vertes et riverains et
donc il avait demandé des bouteilles
dans les caves de versailles justement
j'habitais versailles j'habite juste
bien la villa du collège et j'habitais
rue de satory à ce moment là et donc
j'avais eu l'idée de reims et les
bouteilles à la pompe l'hiver dans leur
cour
alors les doigts au bin oui mais on les
a tous mis sur l'art sur le trottoir et
donc l'abbé pierre pour moi c'est
quelqu'un que j'admire infiniment mais
c'est comme ça sauf que sa voix manque
maintenant oui parce qu'il pousserait
des coups de gueule comme il disait
et je trouve que c'est cool tellement
d'accord c'était quelqu'un de
formidablement attachant oui et de
charismatique et il m'a choisi
il en a été une douzaine de personnes
qu'il a choisi pour parler de lui pour
parler de son action pour la question
qui vous avait confié il ya des gens
tellement formidable chez emmaüs les
gens sur le terrain
formidable donc état et alcide ex oui
ils viennent là on dit handicap
international
tout ça c'est qu'il ya des jeunes en
plein de choses mais oui actuellement
révolte 12 mo mois et si on parlait même
temps moi c'est de voir ces gens qui
sont sur les routes qui sont six mois en
méditerranée qui ça qui vous souhaitez
nous j'ai dit sur internet et on nous
dit on ne répond pas toujours des choses
à bien humblement mais savons nous on a
vécu un exode je veux dire ça pourrait
ça peut si c'était nous qui étions les
syriens ou serait-ce avec les enfants
dans les bras avec rien à mourir mais
même en étant partie sa razzia chacun
justement vous parlez d'enfants votre
film je m'appelle je m'appelle mais
voilà pas d'une chine une jeune femme
jeune fille une petite fille a deux
filles voilà c'est à remous visiter
histoire très poignante en moins sur un
inceste
oui et je sais le point de départ d'un
cesse oui c'est commence à la marque et
donc il est le premier il a été au
festival de venise
j'étais dans la grande salle owens i va
devenir c'était la première protection
ça va merci rien senti beaucoup de
femmes voulaient me parler avec
l'arrivée d'engins de festivals et on a
eu un prix même pour la protection de
l'enfance à abou dhabi génial un
festival de cinéma
vous avez eu un prix qu'ils ont créés
pour la protection de l'enfance d'accord
est ce que c'est de l'argent c'est une
histoire universelle et qui touche tout
le monde qui touche partout oui en ce
moment on parle beaucoup des prêtres et
de tout ça en mai il n'y a pas que dans
les familles oui déjà
qui sait il ya un monde immense
d'ailleurs il ya le mur du non dit ça
fait remonter au lit vous l'avez lu les
deux delphine de vigan rien ne s'oppose
à la nuit
non je n'ai rien pour rire et vous
verrez certains jeunes gens dansent pas
et alors vous avez un projet je sais que
vous filmez tous les jours c'est vrai
c'est extrêmement en ce moment parce que
j'ai trop aimé la petite caméra un bon
film avec mon portable j'ai créatine
tous et je continue je faisais un
journal viadeo
wiseid sur le journal vidéo adoré ça la
vidéo moi je trouve que c'est bien c'est
une violence sur la manière de raconter
les choses tout simplement et comme
j'aime bien et je vais beaucoup écrire
j'étais bon en français en matière
parlant d'écriture vous avez un projet
de libre oui on fait un livre oui ou non
il pouvait me dire j'ai la martinière ça
me met ses talents qui écrit alors c'est
que c'est florence ben sadoun de la
maison oui c'est l'histoire de la maison
l'histoire mac de mes créations
l'histoire du style agnès b d'acs ne
commence à coller gilles agnès b est un
malade qui vous savez vous avez fait
rêver des générations notamment ma
génération de lafayette avec les
cardigans impression les caleçons oui
oui oui génial c'était mythique lac du
jour et oui c'est la galerie et alors
vous êtes aussi une grande grande
amatrice d'art contemporain oui j'ai
voudront garder
voilà beaucoup d'oeuvres ou est ce qu
elles sont elles sont une occasion
d'acheter moi il y en a qu'on prête y en
a qu'on nous emprunte beaucoup héros dc
co édition
ouais et puis on un projet au musée
l'immigration ce ses musées parce que
j'aime beaucoup qui était le musée des
colonies pour dorer on a un projet
l'aveu à ce cours est génial parce que
justement je veux montrer des pièces de
ma collection la ba ouai genre 200 300
pièces jaunes et 3000 pieds mais ça on
va en choisir avec san jose qui est le
directeur des rencontres d'arles est
quelqu'un avec qui je m'entends très
bien et tous les deux on va concevoir
l'exposition et nous a demandé au musée
donc de la porte dorée gonaïves date et
c'est vers le 27 octobre
donc ça va être la première à connaître
la date donc ça va être la première fois
qu'on verra autant de vos ados de rieter
voulant rassembler ce que je vous avais
montré pas mal aux abattoirs à toulouse
oui il ya un incident dont allard et on
peut pas envisager un millier de
nouvelles choses où seraient les 3000
mais mon rêve c'est d'avoir un endroit
une fondation qui serait
dans la banlieue nord en banlieue nord
de versailles de paris dans le nord de
versailles du 13 livres sur la banlieue
parce qu'il a besoin de choses que les
gens ont besoin de nourrir les gens à
ceux des lectures d'aller à leur
rencontre entre chez eux dans la
formation voilà c'est ce qu'on aime
parler de votre collection comme d'un
collage enfin et bien sûr parce que
chaque pièce de la connaît chaque les
choix jument semble intéressant de voir
le collège en entier comme un puzzle
mais à chaque fois on peut faire des
thèmes différents
oui après tout il ya de quoi tu dois
attendre la collection on peut faire
vraiment la jeunesse est très présente
il ya beaucoup de choses les adore vous
avez quel âge d'envoi de tête
pour l'instant j'ai 40 ans car la maison
à 40 ans elle oui mais vous moi j'ai pu
voir une enfant et tout nadeau je vais
pas pouvoir quitter aussi parce que vous
laisse regarder vos yeux bon merci
d'être venu à versailles nous voir ça me
fait super plaisir merci
et puis merci beaucoup on n'est jamais
content c'est un très bel endroit ça va
vous plaire ça nous plaît mais nazaire
les eymes les versaillais et messieurs
des messieurs ouais on va les relooker à
ce que je dessine tout moi même mais oui
j'ai pas studio donc c'est vous qui
faites chaque tour on choisit les
boutons tout bon merci beaucoup à niel
sans merci merci